okay so do you all remember
Aquaman seahorse storm well looks like
he's getting an upgrade in the movie
that's right
we now have sea dragons this morning
Entertainment Weekly gave us another
first look at a massive sea dragon and
it looks awesome
now there's somebody on top of it that
we don't really know who it is but it's
probably King Nereus the article goes on
to tell us that these sea dragons are
ridden by the people of zobelle and
they're one of the seven underwater
kingdoms of Atlantis and their leader is
King Darius and the outline pretty much
looks like him also we will be following
comic-con
all weekend giving you the newest
information that comes out including
trailers pictures all of that stuff so
be sure to hit that subscribe button so
you can stay up to date on everything
that happens in comic-con this weekend
this sea dragon looks awesome I'm so
glad that they're putting this in the
movie many fans were beginning to wonder
if storm
Aquaman seahorse would actually be in
the movie but to me this is so much
better now
they're not really saying that this is
Aquaman again it says that they're
ridden by the Warriors of Sibel but I'm
guessing that at some point in time
Aquaman's gonna ride one of them and
could the one that he rides be possibly
named storm or does he just keep the sea
dragon and he names it storm himself
looks like we're going to have to wait
until the movie comes out to find out
judging by this e w interview with
producer Peter sanfran it does seem like
they're going to be replacing Aquaman
seahorse storm with these sea dragons
this is what he had to say in the
interview the idea was to turn on its
head the idea of Aquaman riding a
seahorse take something for which he was
mocked and turn it into something
terrifying and impressive he's as a
belly and creature but I wouldn't be
surprised if we saw Arthur on one at
some point so based on what Peter
sanfran says I think it's pretty obvious
that these sea dragons will be replacing
his seahorse he was mocked for having a
seahorse in the comics so it would make
sense with the direction that they're
trying to take this movie and the DC EU
that they would replace a seahorse with
a sea dragon this picture makes me
super stoked for Aquaman probably more
than any of the other pictures have that
we've seen so far the sea dragon is huge
massive it is colorful but it's dark at
the same time and it is terrifying and
impressive definitely more fitting for
the movie than a sea horse sorry storm
so what do you all think of this awesome
photo that Entertainment Weekly gave us
this morning does it make you even more
excited to see Aquaman and do you think
that the sea dragon is taking the place
of storm hit me with your thoughts in
the comments below and be sure to like
this video and subscribe to my channel
so you can stay up to date with
everything that is happening with
comic-con this weekend thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you